arvato Supply Chain Solutions cut the
ribbon on a new Logistics Hub it will
play host to meta platforms Incorporated
the parent company of Facebook and
Instagram so it's located not too far
from Tropical Parkway and the 15. 8 news
now reporter Lauren negretti shows us
what it's all about
it's the latest in what's becoming North
Las Vegas's Warehouse District this one
bringing Tech opportunities
introducing meta's Logistics Hub gaseano
is the senior program manager this is
going to be a Distribution Hub servicing
all of our West Coast Network as far as
data center goes Arvada Solutions will
operate the facility Michael konopka
with arvato explains how the warehouse
floor operates so we will be receiving
storing and transforming products
meaning technicals provide Technical
Services arvato plans to work with
temporary agencies to staff the
warehouse kanopka says arvato needed a
location to reach the West Coast that's
why they chose North Las Vegas directly
on the on the 15 so ideal for
transportation mayor Pro tem Scott black
says North Las Vegas has seen a
development boom over the last couple of
years and there's more to come the
unique tech industry that's something
that's new to Southern Nevada and
hopefully it'll be the first of many the
I-15 will be trained transformed from
the speedway all the way out to the Apex
exit you'll see both sides of the of the
highway just lined with great commercial
developments like this black
reporting from North Las Vegas Lauren
negretti 8 News Now